It opened its wings like this and
hovered above me skinny chicken.
Now you are vampires,
and it was Peter.
The vampire is perhaps the most
universally recognizable character in
all of cinema.
The most famous interpretation comes
largely from Bela Lugosi's Dracula in
1931 where we got the classic accent and
widow's peak,
the high collar,
and Kate came from the vampire in
theater and the sharp canines were
popularized by Christopher Lee's horror
of Dracula known as just Dracula in the
UK in 1958 and it's a combination of
these features that leads us to the
image of the vampire we're most familiar
with.
It's the vampire that shows up in cereal
boxes,
Geico commercials,
and sesame street
greetings.
I am the count,
but in reality,
the design of the vampire varies
drastically depending on the movie count
or lock in those Fra to looks like an
evil monster.
But Edward Kulin and twilight is
basically a perfect version of a human.
Each vampire is actually carefully
engineered to serve a certain purpose in
each movie,
and many scholars have studied the
meaning of different vampires over time.
Hey,
my name's Stanley's to panic.
I teach at the University of Virginia.
I'm an associate professor currently,
but I've taught a number of things I've
taught and I'm currently teaching a film
course.
Russian film,
Eastern Europe came down,
but my big courses called Dracula live,
it's about vampires and bunch of other
things.
There's been a fair amount of research
on the vampire in academia,
which makes sense considering Dracula is
the second most popular character in
cinematic history behind the only
sherlock holmes.
And that's not including the majority of
vampire films that don't even have a
dracula ASCII character.
One of the reasons why the vampire is so
popular amongst filmmakers is its
versatility as a creature.
Since the beginning of the vampire
onscreen directors have always made
creative changes to their vampires to
suit their particular movie.
For example,
the vampire,
it's called con aural lab,
not contracting and original.
And it comes from the Dutch,
which means war,
you know?
So obviously there's some connection
there with,
with war and the laws that,
you know,
Mike,
in particular,
young men for Germany during World War
One and the rest of our team.
So wars obvious there.
Um,
yeah.
And it's also clear assemble like
foreign intervention or a fear of name
of grants,
a Jewish immigration maybe or Jewish
influence and we know be unfortunate
finishing the bat and then you had this
thing that,
especially in that case,
which is a human leg,
but it's like it's so foul looking and
it spreads disease that then it really
reiterates the negative connotations
about being Jewish.
Much of the design of Count Orlok is
antisemetic.
He has many features also present in
Jewish characatures including the
association between Jewish people and
rats.
The filmmakers changed or exaggerated
some designs of the original Dracula to
make the creature more relevant to the
fears of post World War One.
Germany
in particular,
they changed the location because it
based and Dracula,
they've changed it from Transylvania for
London,
Transylvania to Germany.
Right.
So obviously they're making connections
to their own college and things that it
represent that.
Yeah.
In that case,
you know,
it's something to be feared because when
it's representing is something that
certain people,
when you've been like
in filmmakers always
customize,
they're vampires to represent something
different.
[inaudible] was a way to symbolize
German fears at the time that largely
included antisemitism.
But the vampire can do much more than
that since vampires aren't technically
human directors have historically used
them to show behavior that would be too
weird or controversial if it were done
by actual humans.
In the 1930s,
homosexuality was essentially banned on
the big screen in America by a series of
moral guidelines called the hays code.
But the vampire found a way to work
around that.
Starting With Dracula in 1931 vampires
quickly switched from disgusting
monsters of Count Oarlock to sex symbols
like Bela Lugosi,
showing just how easily the vampire can
change and how the vampire can mean
something sexual.
Some of the images that we have in
western culture of things that are
horrific are also basically sexual.
Basically,
vampirism is just sex from the neck up.
You're penetrating a passive person.
Um,
it's just,
it really is a very sexual sort of
monster.
Throughout the filming of Dracula's
daughter in 1936,
universal pictures was well aware of the
lesbian implications of a female vampire
gazing at and biting a partially nude
woman.
They changed the script to make lily
clothed and had the camera cut away,
but either with these changes,
the homosexuality is pretty obvious.
The vampire allowed a depiction of
lesbian ism decades before humans could
do it themselves,
even though it isn't explicit ends.
Oleska is also interested in guys in the
film with Vampires.
Controversial topics are much easier to
discuss when you compare movies about
the same topic that came out around the
same time.
Vampires offer enough removal from
actual humans that they can go much
further with the topic.
Philadelphia is about a homosexual suing
a company for wrongly terminating him
because he has aids as the first
mainstream big budget movie focusing on
a homosexual.
The movie approaches the subject very
carefully and Tribeca is written very
sympathetically,
always nice in the camera,
shows it nearly every scene gives us a
shot from his perspective with closeups
and we even get home footage to show how
ordinary he is.
In contrast,
the bad guys are films speaking almost
exclusively in racist and homophobic
slurs often shot from far away,
often shot from behind back.
It doesn't express his sexuality much.
He never kisses his partner and the ones
scenes showing two men sharing a bed
together was cut for the theatrical
release.
In many ways it has to water down so
many aspects of homosexuality to show it
as completely normal.
You survived what I assumed to be your
first gay party and tech.
Now I'm not trying to say that
Philadelphia should have pushed more
boundaries because then it might not
have done well during the time that it
came out.
What I am saying is a vampire movie
could do much more interview with the
vampire came out one year later and
there's an incredible difference in how
far it goes in portraying homosexuality
on screen.
It seemed goes farther.
Yeah.
It shows you like you know where they
almost kiss and stuff and gets really,
really,
you know,
sexually tans in a number of scenes.
So for example,
near of Yam,
whenever I'm on,
just so you know,
with Louie and that our gallery and
Louie draws him really close.
I mean,
they're like,
you know that it's clicks and then let's
start and the way he's connected to
Louie and then they get this daughter or
you know,
I mean it's representing two gay guys.
So they've essentially,
and talking about a child in the back of
nearly 90 it's like I can remember that
being a controversy this guys,
but they liked it.
Right.
And again,
it's,
it makes us like August to vampires
though,
right?
You know,
it's,
it's like right there but not officially
saying it.
Yeah.
When it's pampers,
you can hide your meaning in a symbol.
Then the movie can have more nuanced
characters in discussions.
The movie doesn't need to have to give
us any lectures about homosexuality.
Like Philadelphia does interview with
the vampire marks,
the first piece of work with a first
person perspective of the vampire and it
focuses more on the relationship between
vampires over time.
Not to mention the bitey scenes are
extremely erotic,
more erotic than a movie like
Philadelphia was capable of doing with
real people.
But maybe my favorite example of using a
vampire to be ahead of the times,
his death dream originally titled dead
of Night,
a lesser known movie about a soldier who
dies in Vietnam and returns home as a
creature like a vampire.
The director cleverly uses the vampire
to show what it was like for a veteran
to return home after combat as a totally
different person,
a shadow of their former self,
like Zombie,
like looking corpse thing that is like
near Dad and many before he looks in the
home will be boise sunglasses.
How many acts weird out in public and
his way of responding is very dead.
Like whenever his ex girlfriend or the
girl I used to days talking to me now
that's at one particular scene.
It's really telling where she says,
you know,
I hope you're not,
you're not mad or anything,
says
Ronnie,
which is a really dead response as if
you suck,
you know,
sort of symbolizing that plight of the
Vietnam vet who's like emotionally dead
as he fights his friends and family.
His actions directly mere how Vietnam
veterans were rejected by society and
the media when they came back from war.
It's a powerful message and the director
created a berry humanlike but
emotionally stunted kind of vampire to
show his message.
It's not much different from a movie
like Rambo,
but with a vampire death dream came out
eight years before Rambo and just one
year after the Vietnam War.
In many ways,
the vampire movies are ahead of the
Times.
The vampire was also ahead of its time
in race relations.
The first black horror movie was Black
Ula and it was a box office hit in the
movie.
Dracula strips prince mom Waldy of his
power when he tries to abolish the slave
trade,
cursing him as a vampire.
The movie becomes a quest for black ula
to regain his power and identity.
Any partially does so by fighting off
white policemen attacking a black
community.
Here we see a movie in 1972 already
showing the issues of racial profiling
in the fantasy of black Americans to
fight back,
making it way ahead of its time.
The thing that makes that film boundary
breaking right is that you're getting
vampire,
but he likes it.
Right?
Saint Catherine White people watching
that and then they identify with what's
going on with number Waldo and how that
relates to racial relations.
Right.
Whereas if you showed,
you know,
bunch of,
African Americans and packing the
police,
then you met,
you're probably gonna have some white
people.
It'd be like,
I don't like that.
Same thing happens today whenever the
black lives matter.
Talking about police intervention in
black communities,
stuff like that,
that when you got to have an empire and
they're sort of bridges that gap and
brings people together in a different
way.
And so the modern vampire carries all
these past iterations of the vampire
with it.
This may seem silly to even talk about,
but even a kid show on Disney channel
uses the symbol of vampires to talk
about human issues.
I mean,
it's obvious right there what that shows
is doing.
It's basically symbolizing a different
culture or a different race.
They were character.
That's fun so that kids can understand
it better.
No,
I've always thought they were the
greatest metaphor for the outsider in
all of us.
I felt like an outsider growing up.
I miss fed.
I think a lot of people did or do it
sometime in their life feel like
outsiders,
outkast and the vampire is a great way
to talk about that.
He's,
he's a larger than life,
mythic hero who is looks human and can
talk to you like a human being,
but it's actually a monster and he's
immortal.
He's outside of life and I think that's
a great metaphor for human beings.
The show has episodes where neighbors
come to terms with the odd van
stereotypes this family follows.
Using a vampire makes it simple for kids
to understand,
and it's not controversial.
It would be a little trickier to address
black or Asian stereotypes to a little
kid in a TV series,
but if fake creature is a lot easier,
it's actually a great example of why
more complicated ideas like
homosexuality,
race relations in the effects of war or
more easily discussed using a vampire
instead of a human.
I'll go for one more example.
That's a bit out there.
Why did twilight do so well?
It's definitely not the writing.
The book copies a very common storyline
in tons of female,
young adult literature.
A story of an attractive bad boy with a
bad background who is dangerous in some
way,
whether it's from drugs or abuse,
and he meets a girl who changes him.
Typically it's through some very average
girl that he becomes a better pair of
Stan because of law,
right?
And that's the idea that love,
we can change the world and there's this
guy out there that's going to pick me,
right?
And no one else notices me and this
guy's going to pick me and he's totally
awesome,
but I'm the one that's going to lead to
that totally awesome because he's going
to be on me.
Twilight follows this storyline
extremely closely,
as have dozens of novels before it,
but making the bad boy of empire is
actually kind of creative.
That creature is perfect for that
fantasy.
They're usually attractive,
at least in some modern movies.
They don't age and they can't be killed,
but at the same time,
vampires are dangerous.
They could hurt you in.
They're extremely strong.
There's that famous scene whenever
they're about the case and he jumps back
because he's afraid of going too far
because he could end up harming,
harsh and see us,
you know,
even vague.
So that danger that he represents is
this bad boy image.
It's not really his fault so to speak,
which is what makes him a little more
sellable to because he just needs to be
like find the right human being.
So that movie and novel craft of Vampire
that works as a bad boy and young girls
identify with the girl.
It's a fantasy for young girls that's
always been around.
But the vampire gives it a new spin and
allows the fantasy to be explored a
little deeper because at the end of the
day,
the bad boy fantasy isn't real.
That's not how real life works.
So using a fake creature instead of a
human,
let's you go further with the fantasy
just like you can with other complicated
issues as a great sum up of Vampires
over time,
the company,
what we do in the shadows helps us
understand the power of the vampire as a
symbol overall.
The van in the movie are all from
different time periods and to
influences.
Peter's Terrifying Monster Portrayal
Echoes Count Oarlock in Nosferatu
Flautas lavs teams influenced by
Vladislav in Dracula,
Si,
and nick has similarities to Edward from
twilight even admitting it himself,
they'll maybe twilight if you say no,
I'm the main guy,
twilight
mockumentary.
We follow around these vampires in their
everyday lives and in a weird way,
the format and style actually teaches us
a lot about vampires in media.
We get documentaries when we think about
it.
It's worthy of a documentary,
so I'll make it about a serious good
product and therefore you'll learn about
the nature of the product by studying
the series.
This film,
it is really doing something quite
special.
It's saying you can learn just as much
by studying something lousy.
When you're a vampire you become very
sexy.
This movie shows us what it would really
be like if vampire's existed.
It wouldn't be epic like and all these
other movies.
It would actually be ridiculous.
They would have to find a place to live.
They would have to clean their flat and
biting someone wouldn't always be
dramatic and theatrical.
Sometimes it would just be silly.
What we do in the shadows shows how
every other vampire movie artificially
creates a vampire to suit their own
meaning by showing us every vampire in
film history,
in one movie,
we realize just how different they all
are,
and it's true.
Some vampires look disgusting to show
fears of disease and antisemitism summer
basically perfect versions of humans,
and there's everything in between.
And the traits of the vampire always
means something.
It represents not really human problems
in a way that makes it accessible
because it's fine.
I vampires are fun and it makes it
indirect so that it's kind of save it
and discuss it.
You now,
when you're talking about a band pie
that symbolizes racial identity and of
talking about those issues in a direct
way
and that little bit of distance from
actual human floods,
the vampire really pushed boundaries and
be ahead of its time.
So the next time you watch a vampire
movie,
maybe you can see a powerful message
based on what they do or don't do.
Vampires don't do dishes,
and maybe you'll learn about vampires in
a new and different way,
which is what these videos are supposed
to be all about.
Oh,
I bet like this the better.
Because students like his stuff more and
you know it's,
it's it,
it encapsulates more information to
share now stays and so it's where things
are going,
but it's in academia just doesn't want
to shift.
Yeah,
it's starting to,
but it really needs to,
you know?
Yeah.
Okay.
One of the most important novels for the
vampire is I am legend.
The original book has the first
scientific vampire,
one that's not supernatural,
but caused by an actual disease.
It's a big influence for night of the
living dead.
A movie that paves the way for the
modern Zombie.
So yes,
that means the zombies we see today
partially originate from vampires.
You can listen to this book today using
audible,
and I really recommend you check it out.
The original book is so much better than
the Will Smith movie version in 2007 go
to audible.com/now you see it to get a
30 day trial.
And your first audio book for free or
text.
Now you see it to 500 500 to get
started.
Audible content includes an unmatched
selection of audiobooks,
original audio shows,
news,
comedy,
and more from the leading audio book,
publishers,
Broadcasters,
entertainers,
magazine,
and newspaper publishers,
and business information providers.
Audible really does make commuting
bearable,
maybe even enjoyable if you get the
right book.
I am,
legend definitely works.
So go to audible.com/now you see it for
the free trial and any audio book for
free or text.
Now you see it to 500 500 to get
started.
Thanks for watching.